good morning uh as I stated my name is
Alan over I'm the officer with the
public information office with the city
of Henderson Police Department
I'm here to give an initial briefing on
an officer-involved shooting that
occurred today September 26 2022 in the
city of Henderson in the west Patrol
Division
this is the second officer-involved
shooting for 2022.
at 6 55 a.m uh
officers were dispatched to a man with a
gun call
at the 10 000 block
Southeastern Avenue
arriving officers made contact
with the described subject
who then produced what was believed to
be a handgun resulting in an
officer-involved shooting
the suspect male
suffered from a gunshot wound
and officers began life-saving measures
the suspect Mill was transported to a
local area hospital where he later
succumbed to his injuries
the involved officer
suffered an injury from the incident was
also transported to a local area
hospital where he is said to be in
stable condition
if you guys have questions on uh let's
see who's had a couple questions here I
guess the first one would be uh was
there an exchange of fire at any point
you said it was believed to be a weapon
that he was producing and that's why the
officers went ahead and used that Force
I don't have the specifics on how the
incident unfolded
um from the point of contact to the
involved shooting site once that
information is gathered that'll be put
together in a great impression press
release later are you able to speed on
the nature of the officer's injury
I don't have the specifics on his injury
all I've just updated with was that he
is in stable condition
officer could you say why the suspect
was in the area where they handgun to
begin with that information has not come
to light just yet it's still an
investigation at this time
um
I'm sorry did the man have a gun
the the suspect male had what is
believed to be a handgun yes that's what
was believed to be
um that's all as far as questions right
now you guys I do want to make sure and
reiterate that this is still a early
investigation
um with as it's active and ongoing and
as this investigation continues and more
details are gathered we will be able to
push that out to you guys in a written
statement at a later time I do have a
request for the public if anybody was in
the area or involved in any way or
witnessed anything if they can contact
our investigations unit at 702-267-4750
really appreciate any help or any
witnesses to come forward to the
incident please thank you how long can
we expect this area to be shut down like
this for
years